people in Yucatan eat Habaneros with
everything
oh my God oh my God
oh
spicy
this is really spicy oh my
[Music]
God guys I'm in L.A and of course I have
to explore Mexico I'm meeting up with
Bill Esparza the taco scholar I'm so
excited because I've heard many
legendary things about him he's like an
encyclopedia of knowledge
I mean it is LA and of course the queen
of oaxacan food bricia Lopez I've been
wanting to meet her for a long time
because I feel like this is going to be
maybe the spiciest episode but I'm not
sure we'll see
there's bill over there
spot you from a mile away hey hey hey
what's up Phil good to see you good to
see you
so today I'm going to be taking you to
three states of Mexico we're going to
start in Sinaloa with Del Mar ostioneria
for aguachiles tennis off to Oaxaca
Candelaria is coming out to cook a spicy
mole and then we're going to try ekbalam
they're from the Yucatan and we're going
to be eating Habaneros with them Let's
do let's get some seafood yes I'm so
excited hi welcome to Del Mar what's
happening how are you how are you Hi man
nice to meet you nice to meet you okay
nice to meet you we want to try your
spicy ago
and with lots of that Chile chilte pin
you got it we like it spicy I like it
spicy we'll make it spicy for you the
chipped the bean pepper is the specialty
on the straw they're little round balls
and dried and they're super flavorful I
to me they're more like a Chili Garbo
okay heat maybe even hotter sometimes
okay pretty spicy but with even more
flavor okay why are we starting here
Chile is is known for being a spicy uh
style of Ceviche and so people order
that because they want heat why is
Mexico sort of like all about Chili
Peppers it's the only culture where it's
a part of our entire Cuisine it's not
just a condiment it's not just used for
heat it's it's in everything it's in
soups it's in stews it's in moles dried
smoked you know fresh Chiles the origin
of the chili pepper all the research
points to South America near the Amazon
where wild peppers first appeared those
peppers were carried by birds they don't
have the heat receptors receptors right
and so it doesn't affect them so they
would poop out the seeds so Birds
carried them into Central America and to
what we know now today is Mexico it's
the birds the birds but we also have to
thank the indigenous people of Mexico
that cultivated these seeds right and
they were like oh these Chili Peppers
and came up with all the ones those 64
different Chiles we know today right
it's going to be all right cheers wow
that is gorgeous oh the ring molds
yeah show me the story I know what
you're thinking you're thinking this is
a truck we're at a food truck and you're
like this isn't Mexican street food but
in Sinaloa there is a professional uh
chef-driven industry this Chef is
trained he was a corporate Chef for a
restaurant group okay Sinaloa so they
bring that professionalism and the
plating and then also the Japanese
influence of working in sushi bars and
things like that in Brandon just bring
in the condiments soy ponzu this is like
Nobu at a food truck seriously like it's
so beautifully plated and you said that
there's Specialties using these the
children beautiful
it's the dust on top
that has heat that has heat right now oh
yeah
it is so flavorful
and it definitely the heat is there it's
it's like not mild by any means all of
these these Chiles hit differently in
different parts of your mouth that won't
work okay there you go so you got it
but you just want to keep going back for
more but also because of the acid and
the lime juice it just like rounds it
out nicely when I'm looking for a spot I
always think Little Mexico versus big
Mexico there's a there's a taco chain
here called tacos Mexico and I don't
know what that means because there are
32 regions a place that's representing a
state or a town
um is going to bring that specific
flavor and that pride and that culture
for me I just want to eat this in every
bite yeah
it's a really really delicious flavor it
packs a punch
[Music]
so Bill where are you taking us to now
our next stop is La Plaza Cocina which
is a museum why are we eating at a
museum well the museum has a demo
kitchen and so we're meeting Lopez from
galaguetza and Candelaria who's from La
mixteca of Oaxaca she drove all the way
from Santa Maria they're going to cook
some mole for us
[Music]
there's Bruce yeah what's up hey hey
girl hey hi how are you how are you good
to see you it's gonna freak out when I
tell him I'm gonna like have break bread
with you break tortilla with you what's
your son's name what's up Eduardo oh
he's gonna die he's gonna show me all
things mole I am your girl for all your
modeling needs yeah
a
oake
delicious spicy which is a very big
difference
it's not sweet so in Mexico we have this
in Oaxaca there's a saying this is like
[Music]
and then when it's another one it's kind
of a bad word
foreign
oh it gets hardened with the sun and
then she and then she toasts it on the
komal and when you do with the Comal
when you chose that you're adding that
Smoky flavor like this you're getting
all this it's almost like blooming as
spice right same thing as you're
blooming you're blooming that you left
you get so toasty to the point where
it's like a chip
right but you can't burn it no that's
like that that's the art of a mole so
then is this like Blended together with
water the way it works is she'll make
all of the Chiles powder up and to make
it like a doughy consistency she'll add
water when it comes to the nuts uh
she'll grind all that like in a blender
and then separately she'll do the
tomatoes onion garlic and then all the
spices and then she'll start tasting it
and let's say if it's missing like a
spice she'll add more so it's all by
feel and taste yeah what are some of the
misconceptions behind mole calling it a
chocolate sauce like if that irks me I'm
from the valley of Oaxaca
um where our mole is very different how
is it different so or mole has more of a
sweet undertone and where's the
chocolate oh with the chocolate that's
always using it so I just think it's a
matter of like seasoning it so is it a
chili sauce that it's the dish it is and
everything that's on the plate you use
to eat the mole so finished yeah
[Music]
see wow better
it's a magic powder that we're suicide
girl
that is delicious and definitely spicy
absolutely delicious for me it just
tastes like this is what Oaxaca tastes
like my mom's gonna serve what a
traditional plate would look like which
would be mole chicken rice and beans I'm
so excited oh my God
oh for me gracias that's amazing look at
that
come on in a place
and what's up with the boiled chicken
you don't want any other thing to
interfere you want to taste the mole yes
correct form as possible
hence the boiled chicken like I never
thought mole to be spicy but everybody
thinks it's like three right yeah but I
think that's just like the beauty of
obviously not just like 100 Mexican food
so much more than just whatever people
think it builds up it's the bills it's
getting there thank you so much this was
exceptional
so incredible
thank you
okay Bill where are we off to next
well we're gonna go to Monterey yo Elsa
Juan and Rocio they have a pop-up called
ecbalam now ecbalan is a family from the
Yucatan people in Yucatan eat Habaneros
with everything they eat raw Habaneros
with their food they chase their Taco
bites their bites of cochinita that's
crazy that's crazy yeah so are we here
this is it this is it
it's a neighborhood
so I've heard a lot about this style of
cooking and people going to people's
backyards and eating
front yard living rooms everything
garages yeah it's a thing it's a thing
and our street style our street rigs
cooking with fire all these things it's
very hard to do it in a restaurant
kitchen and we also like the the
Ambiance we like being outside but it's
cute it is so cute
thank you so much for inviting us to
your home oh thank you very very excited
very excited it smells delicious it does
smell delicious yeah it smells like oh
yeah
hola look at those the habanero you
match
some of the habaneros I do oh my gosh
I'm at habanero today so I'm pretty
excited for you guys to try my food
today so very very excited she's my
mentor and she showed me a lot for the
traditional cuisine of Yucatan amazing
basically in Yucatan is everything is
the street food and everything
everything very spicy yeah no mild salsa
no no no is it okay if I if I hang out
and watch is it filled with something
yeah black bean puree it's a handmade
tortilla you don't know how it fluffs up
yeah so we open it and we stuff it with
black bean puree and then you fry it and
then you fry it kind of resembles a
little bit when I go to Yucatan I kind
of like to see sisters used to kind of
dance called harana if you see the the
way they're dressed and if you see the
food it just stands out like that
I'm so excited right now and we have
this other one it's wow so it's just
straight yes yeah straight habanero
oh yeah it's like that sweet like
intense heat Chef what is in your
coaching when we do our Chote paste we
put um cinnamon sticks we put a little
bit of oregano and some other spices
that my mom usually teaches me to Ajo
garlic and once we start blending
everything we start making the paste
I love how she's like
don't forget it trust me that's why like
it took me forever
this is it it looks beautiful that's
amazing Chef it looks amazing thank you
oh my gosh
we have an antojito traditional panucho
a panucho is actually a handmade
tortilla stuff with black bean puree we
add lettuce a shredded chicken adobo
Tomatoes pickled onions the second dish
that we have here too is that we have
the traditional called chinita pivil
that comes with the pickled onions as
well then can you tell us about your
Salsa Salsa well it's actually we just
grilled them a little bit just to get a
little charcoal so it's almost pure
spicy yeah I'm gonna follow your lead
let's start with a panucho panucho me
I'm going for it you are
I don't mess around hey if it's about
the Habaneros I'm gonna go for that one
there pure flavor do you think that I'm
gonna die I well we're gonna find out
[Music]
spicy
too right away oh
okay see this is true heat when it goes
straight to your head and you feel dizzy
you when you get light-headed slightly
mm-hmm
I love that feeling actually it did go
straight to my head but then it's okay
that's what I'm saying you have to ride
the wave
gracias raw habanero Chef this is
amazing so delicious and the Heat
it's there yeah
this tastes like the Yucatan It's a
Wonderful marinade
it's awesome that tortilla
is everything I want to try this because
I think I can handle it
oh my God oh my God
say oh my yeah
it's very very hot
oh
spicy
let's let's Taco
Yucatan style right take a bite and then
so you take a bite it's called like a
little mine it's niche yes
it's kind of like to get a shot right
you take a shot and then Chase with the
top so here we go all right
all right
once you have the bite you don't feel it
actually yeah
it's fruity there we go how are we doing
I respect you yeah I mean we earned the
respect I'm sweating but I love this I
love it I love the feeling it's a high
you get high oh my God don't you feel
like this natural air conditioning I'm
like cold right now from the uh from the
Habaneros your body sweats and your your
temperature drops it makes a lot of
sense that Mayans were eating this way
free AC you guys pretty easy guys gotta
come visit Chef Juan over here great way
to end the tour thank you so much Phil
you're awesome
thank you thank you I need to learn more
I want more spice all right
[Music]
okay
is this your first elote Loco
see how could you not love this it's the
flaming hot yeah
oh
quite spicy yeah it is spicy
oh my God I can't stop eating it it's so
good
[Music]
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching oh God that was
spicy
please like And subscribe and to watch
more episodes click here